welcome back to game on vegas las vegas
jordan made a name for himself
right here in las vegas winning big at
gorman
then he went on to the university of
miami to play for the keynes the
hurricane now
he's got his eye on the upcoming nfl
draft he's one of the best college tight
ends
and hopes to build his skills in the nfl
we caught up with brevin
as he wraps up school in miami and waits
for the biggest challenge of his life
earning a spot on an nfl roster i'm good
i'm good i'm training i'm
getting my body back to put to full
extent i'm uh
getting my body right fully getting
bigger getting stronger getting faster
in all aspects of
everything is good man it feels good to
be back home yeah did you miss las vegas
i missed it so much i miss my mom's
home-cooked food that's what i missed
most but being a miami was a great
experience what's your
favorite meal your mom makes
probably just basic korean barbecue
honestly i'm korean so yeah she makes a
lot of korean barbecue you just have a
lot of side dishes on the side so you
can't go wrong with that
but i'm hearing some great things from
all these draft gurus about
uh the opportunities ahead for you yeah
i'm really excited i'm real
more so anxious though i want to just
get out there to my draft day and show
the coaches
and the owners and gm's and everybody
that you know i'm cable i can i'm a
playmaker
do you miss the fact that there's no uh
combine in indianapolis this year
yeah definitely that's that's a part of
like the dream you know growing up you
want to go to indianapolis you know you
want to run the 40 have the camera put
all on you but
it's all right though i'm not i'm not
really down about it what do you see
yourself kind of
uh as you've progressed i'm just a
playmaker i'm
overall i'm gonna move tight in i could
be put on any put in the backfield
at wide out in the slot at wing t like
in air in any formation like you could
put me anywhere i'm a playmaker
produce for the team how fun has it been
any regrets at all signing with miami if
you had to go back and do it all again
if i had to do it all over again i would
have signed exactly with miami again
that was great that was a great
experience you know we didn't win
we didn't win you know to the standard
that i'm used to at gorman like a
national championship but
the the value is in everything that i
was taught there you know i'ma carry
with me the rest of my life
looks like your dreams are coming true
yeah they're coming at you it's crazy it
really is
a a humbling yet crazy experience to me
because i remember
like just yesterday i was a freshman at
gorman just enrolling with
being coached under coach bergman and
like just being a part
of that like just a part of a team you
know like a real like a real
united football team and now i'm about
to go to the nfl like it's
[Applause]
76 ridiculous all right one of the good
guys here in las vegas we'll see what
unfolds as the nfl draft approach is
still two months away
but you've seen mock drafts already
where will brev and jordan go in the
draft fun to follow here on channel 8.
we're also gearing up for some big
events here on channel 8 related to the
draft we'll share some of those details
as we
roll closer to those dates we're
planning on having a real good time on
draft day so we will certainly
keep you posted